>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Stephanie Stillo: So welcome
everyone to our Thursdays
at Three talk here
in Rare Books.
We are very delighted to
have you here this afternoon.
Today, we have Alexander Knirim.
We're still working on his last,
I am still working
on his last name.
He's a doctoral student
at the Department
for Early Modern History at the
University of Beirut in Germany.
He currently occupies the
position of Bavarian Fellow
at the Kluge Center
here at the Library,
and I have to say he has
been truly a delight to work
with over the last couple month.
So you are in for a treat.
Alexander's work focuses
largely on Atlantic history
in the 19th Century,
particularly German communities
in British North America
in the early United States,
and thinking about the way
that print media impacts those
communities, and his project
for Kluge is entitled
German Imprints
in British North America
in the 18th Century
and the Construction of a
German-Speaking Community.
What I find so exciting
about Alexander's work is
that it offers us, I think, a
new vantage from which to look
at really familiar
material, right.
We think we know about almanacs,
right, and Alexander is here
to teach us more about things
that we feel familiar with.
Shamefully, I have never really
stopped to think about the role
of German almanacs in
colonial America, shamefully.
So when he told me
about his research,
I was tremendous excited
about the possibility,
for him certainly and what
he can uncover, but again,
selfishly, what we can learn
about our own collections,
thinking about them
in this new way.
So we're very pleased to be
able to give Alexander a place
to discuss his ongoing
projects and to get feedback
from such a wonderful and
knowledgeable audience
that we have here for
the Thursdays at Three.
So just very quickly
a few organizational
and procedural points.
I realize that most of you
are veterans of our Thursdays
at Three talks, but
for those of you
that are new, just
a couple things.
Alexander will speak
for about 40 minutes,
and after which we
will take questions.
I realize that we are
all tremendously eager
about the 18th Century,
but if we could please keep
the questions until the end,
that would be terrific.
It'll keep us on schedule.
We do have several items that
are out for display that have
to do with Alexander's research.
Again, as I say, we are
excited that you are excited,
but let us handle the material.
We will turn pages for you, and
we will share as much as we can.
With that, please help
me welcome Alexander.
[ Applause ]
>> Alexander Knirim: Stephanie,
thank you so much
for those kind words.
I try to keep up to them.
Good afternoon, ladies
and gentlemen.
I'm very glad to be
here at the Rare Books
and Special Collection
Division of the Library
of Congress today presenting
to you a talk title,
Before you Read, You Should
Look, Front Cover Images
of German Almanacs
in Early America.
What I'm going to do in the
next 45 minutes is to present
and compare front cover images
of German language almanacs
printed before the end
of the Revolutionary War.
Before I start, I want
to thank Michael North,
who suggested the talk in the
first place, and Eric Fraser,
who was extremely helpful
with any questions I had
in the course of my research.
I also want to thank all the
staff of the Rare Book Division
who were so supportive, and
if I would thank everyone
in the way they deserve, we
would celebrate Christmas
in here, so I skip
that a little.
For everyone who never
has done research
in the Rare Book Division, I
just want to encourage you to go
and use the wonderful
materials they can offer you.
I also want to thank
the John W. Kluge Center
and the Bavarian American
Academy in Munich, Germany,
which offered me the opportunity
to come to Washington.
Here, your eyes see for the
first time an almanac usable
for this part of the
world but produced
after the German have it,
which I hope in this county,
which is so far away from
our homeland it's going
to be not unpleasant.
Those are the words which
whom the first German language
almanac announced
it's appearance
in the British colonies
in North America
until the title [foreign
language],
what can be translated as the
German [inaudible] carrying
with it the moral calendar .
This was in 1731, and at the
end of the Revolutionary War,
over 50 years later,
German language almanacs
had become well established
calendars in the then freshly
forged United States of America.
The path from a British to
the [inaudible] was rocky
and especially in
the time around
and after the war a
controversial one.
But, nevertheless, almanacs
survived and played as well
in the 19th Century a key
roll in American history,
and they have done
so until today.
But while many of you know
Benjamin Franklin's Poor Richard
Almanac, most of you
are probably not aware
of German language almanacs
and their publication
history in North America.
What defines a German
almanac in the 18th Century?
What made it German
rather than British
or British North American.
First of all, they were
published in German.
The other important thing is
that they followed the design
of almanacs produced in the
German-speaking territories
in Europe so that German
settlers could easily handle the
almanacs calculated for the
new lands they were going
to live on.
It is also worth mentioning that
all German almanacs were printed
in Fraktur, a typical type,
a typical German
type for this time.
English settlers in many
cases were using Ithaca.
Benjamin Franklin, who printed
in German as well as in English,
obtained some German
meaning Fraktur types
to print German books and
pamphlets in the style
that Germans were used to.
And even then, it was hard
for him and his associates
to compete with printers
like [inaudible],
which were the most
serious competitors
to Franklin's press
regarding German settlers.
About nine German
almanacs were produced
in North America before the
end of the Revolutionary War.
Of course, they didn't
appear all at once
and while some were printed
annually for decades,
others were only
published for a short time.
Finding those almanacs
today is not always easy.
Almanacs could be produced
at relatively low cost
and were often thrown away after
the year they were printed for.
And for some almanac
series, it is impossible
to reconstruct the
whole circulation.
Another problem is
that sometimes the name
of an almanac changes
slightly although layout
and printer say the same.
What appears to be a new almanac
is sometimes an older one
with a slightly different name.
Let me give you an example.
One almanac in 1778 is
named [foreign language],
brand-new North American
calendar, and two years later,
the name is [foreign language],
so brand-new, improved
and reliable North
American calendar.
The changes are not
large, I have to admit,
but in the Library
catalogue, you are not able
to find the almanac
without the proper name,
and cataloguers often have not
recognized that these almanacs
with different titles are
part of the same series.
Almanacs were widespread and
produced in large numbers,
and together with
nongovernmental texts,
they were commonly among the
first publications of printers.
Over the last 20 years,
researchers have
analyzed almanacs
from various perspective,
discussing the shift
of language, grammar,
and the different topics,
which were discussed
in those almanacs.
Today, I am going to pursue a
different angle, the development
of the front covers of German
almanacs in the 18th Century.
What we have here on this
slide, is the first cover
of the [foreign language].
As you can see short
titles were [inaudible].
So 1778, and what we see
here is a typical title page
of an almanac, which commonly
appears as the third page,
if we count the front
cover as page one,
giving us the full
title, the year,
how many days this year has.
So if it is a common year, 364
days, or a leap year with 366.
We can also find the
number of the issue,
the table of contents,
the place it was produced,
who produced it,
and in many cases,
there's also an indication
of where you can find it other
parts of British North America.
Obviously, a lot of those
details are missing here
in this example, and
the explanation is
that this is not the title
page but the front cover.
On this cover page, the printer,
Matthew Barctus [phonetic]
apologizes to the reader
and promised to offer a proper
front cover in the next issue.
The excuse he gives
to you, the reader,
is that the engraver was not
able to finish the cover page
in time, so he only could
publish it in a plain font.
What Barctus mentioned here
explicitly copper engraving,
we should be aware that in
the British colonies different
styles of engravings were used.
Copper engravings, which
were produced for instance
by Matthew Clarkson on Second
Street in Philadelphia,
they are very rare
at the period.
Far more common were
woodcuts, a technique,
which was broadly used
in the United States
after the 20th Century.
This almanac, which is dated
1718, is the earliest issue
with the proper front cover,
which can be found here
in the Rare Books Division
of the Library of Congress.
Matthew Barctus obviously
got his engraving,
and really it is
an interesting one.
What we can see here
is the following.
A man, having only one healthy
leg and the other one replaced
by a wooden stick is
delivering a sealed paper
to two people while
leaning on a spear.
On it's back, he has a bag.
The person, who seems
to receive the letter,
appears to be a man dressed
like aristocrat of the time,
wearing a wig and holding
a stick in his left hand.
In the front, we
can see a snail.
The other person is a woman,
maybe also wearing a wig
and a long robe, which
is falling on the ground.
And if you think that this
person is not like a woman
to me, let me show you
this almanac printed
in German in 1816.
As you can see, the
persons look very similar
to the ones we have seen
before in the one from Barctus,
and even though we have more
people receiving the letter
in this example from 1816,
here we can easily determine
that person we can see on
the front cover is a woman.
But, let us go back
to the one from 1718.
The title of this almanac is
written on the front cover
as [foreign language].
And above the delivery man,
you can read [foreign language]
which can roughly be translated
as the lame messenger.
The [foreign language] was one
of the most successful almanac
in the region between
modern Switzerland,
southern Germany, and France.
The first one was established
in 1677, and afterwards,
many other almanacs were
produced under the same name,
and the tradition
goes on until today.
With that in mind, the
image Barctus has chosen
for his almanac has to be
considered as a common topic
for many German settlers
arriving in North America.
[Inaudible] as many
German settlers
in the 18th Century came
from southwestern German
where this kind of
almanac was popular.
Even though there's an ongoing
discussion about the use
and the development of
almanacs like [foreign language]
in France, Germany,
and Switzerland,
the impact of the front covers
of German almanacs produced
in early America have not
been discussed in detail aside
from some remarks by
[foreign language]
and [foreign language].
And, as the front
cover image combined
with the title is
quite a popular one,
I'm going to show you that even
without the title we can find
images that have recourse
to the [foreign language].
In 1739, Kristof Saur started
his almanac called the [foreign
language] without
the front page.
And this is not a good example.
I used this one from 1747.
And the front cover
itself was added
to the almanac five
years earlier in 1742,
so before that in the first
three years there is simply no
front cover.
It became one of the most
successful German almanacs
in the 18th Century in
British North America.
Saur Sr. and his son, Saur
Jr., are both crucial figures
when we talk about German
printers at that time.
Not just because the
almanacs were one
of the most successful German
printings in the colonies
with a circulation up
to 10,000 per year,
but also because
of the influence
on the German settlers living
not only in German-where
but elsewhere in
Pennsylvania and beyond.
As we mentioned earlier,
first the father
and then his son had a long-time
rivalry with Benjamin Franklin
and some of his fellow
printers in Philadelphia,
partly because Franklin
accused Saur
of not wanting German
settlers to assimilate
into British American society.
You have to be aware that in the
second half of the 18th Century,
about 50 percent
of the Pennsylvania
population was German
or at least trace their origin
back to German ancestors.
By way of comparison, in
the U.S. Census of 2000,
about 15 percent of all
Americans had German ancestors.
And as we have introduced the
two printers, Saur Sr. and Jr.,
already, we're now
going to take a look
on the almanac [foreign
language] calendar.
What we can see on this slide
is one of the first issues
of the [foreign language]
calendar,
and what we can observe
at the first glance is
that we have much more going
on here than we have seen
on the two almanacs before.
We can divide this almanac
roughly into three sections.
One, is the scene in the front
of the almanac, the depiction
of the city and finally
the section showing us
in the heaven.
What we see in the front is a
scene where two people meet.
One of them seems to
be arriving by ship
and was just brought
ashore in a small boat,
which is now tied to a pier.
He is handing over a
letter to the other person,
who is very difficult
to identify.
He or she, that is not clear,
is wearing a long robe, a hat,
which is not so familiar,
as for instance the
tricorn the other man wears,
and in the left hand, she
or he is holding a stick,
receiving the letter with
his or her right hand.
While the letter is passed over,
the man who is delivering
it points with his left arm
in the direction
of the countryside.
In the front, we
can also see a dog.
What is the lands
the man is pointing?
The answer to this
question is giving us
from the city in the background.
The city we see is Philadelphia,
and it is particularly
interesting to observe
that the development of the
city was shown to us by Saur.
First, the senior, since 1758
his son going by the same name,
taking the development of
the city into consideration,
adding new churches
and buildings
in the 1760's and 1770's.
But I will come back to
that in a few minutes.
Let us finish the general
depiction with a look
at the upper part
of the front cover.
Occupy nearly half of
the available space,
what we see is a cloudy sky
and to Hermes holding
a [foreign language].
It looks like Hermes is walking
on a rainbow and has more wings
on his feet, hand, and hat.
His hands, in his hands,
he is holding a banner
that is flying over his hat.
The banner shows us after
1760 different messengers
in different issues
of the almanac.
On the right side, we
see the sun shining,
and on the left side, we see
clouds, and in later examples,
we find they are the moon
and the stars shining.
Let us know analyze this
type of page step by step,
starting with the front area.
When we look at the different
topics presented to us
by the printer, it
seems to remind us
of the front cover
we've seen before.
The handing over of the
letter, the [inaudible]
and partly even the clothes
of the people involved
looking a lot like some
of the elements we saw in
the [foreign language],
but we are missing
one important,
very important feature,
the wooden leg.
So what do we have here?
How can we explain what the
printer is presenting to us?
Is there a connection to
other German almanacs?
We can assume that
Saur Sr., who was born
in German near Heidelberg
was familiar with the concept
of the [foreign language]
or the [foreign language].
At least this type of almanac
was widespread in the region
in the 17th and 18th Century.
Using a familiar image
to sell a German almanac
to German settlers in
the British colonies
in North America was
a smart thing to do.
Many of the early settlers
came from the western
and southern regions of the
German-speaking territories
in Europe, and for that reason,
we're probably familiar
with the concept.
The image of the [foreign
language] became popular
after the 30 Years War in
the 1600's when many wounded
or maimed soldiers
were used as messenger.
Although they were far
slower than the messengers
on horseback, they were at the
same time considered as carriers
of true messages that
everyone could rely on.
So, using a familiar
image for the illustration
of an almanac is smart.
People could recognize
the affiliation
and would probably
feel attracted by it.
If there were a wooden
leg in the image,
the explanation would be easy.
Sadly enough we don't have it.
For that reason, a direct
connection between the ink
and the border in Saur's
almanac seems unlikely,
but aside from the
question of the wooden leg,
the layout strikes as familiar.
Could there be a connection
to the ink in the border
without him being present?
It must be admitted that the ink
in the border was not really
relevant to the delivery of news
in the British colonies where
most news arrived by ship.
The whole narrative
of a wooden leg seems
to be redundant regarding the
fact that it makes no difference
when you are using a ship if
you have a healthy, wooden,
or even no leg at all.
Another explanation could be the
hope for peace in the colonies.
When Saur started his
almanac in the 1730's,
there was still an ongoing
discussion about the defense
of the colonies in which
Saur and many Germans
around him stood
close to the Quakers
and their pacifist approach.
As far as we know,
Saur was clever enough
to use a familiar concept
without explicitly
showing the part
which would contradict his
idea of a peaceful society.
In the end, we cannot be certain
whether Saur really used the
concept of the ink and the
border to better his chances
of selling the almanac.
The very idea of a messenger
delivering news is omnipresent
in the context of the front
cover, but if it was connected
to the ink in the border
or an enhancement of it,
is a question probably
were never going to answer.
Let us know take a
closer look to the city.
As mentioned before, the front
cover shows us the skyline
of Philadelphia.
But what is really interesting
apart from the simple view is
that Saur's adjusted
the skyline over time.
After the first almanac was
produced Saur Sr. states
with the first layout
until his death in 1758.
His son then started
to make small changes.
First, in 1760, so he added
some buildings to the city,
highlighted here, and in 1770,
he redesigned some buildings,
so changed the shape
of the steeples.
But let us focus on
the city itself first.
Up to 1760, the front
cover looked
like we have seen it before.
The city was now shown
in a detailed way.
We can see two towers or
steeples and two paths leading
to the point where we,
the observer, stand.
At the time when this
front cover was used,
there simply were not
many buildings to display.
Only a few had been built when
the front cover first appeared
at the beginning of 1742.
At that time, [inaudible]
produced from a woodcut
which was most likely
made by Saur himself.
The steeple tower on the left
is probably the state house,
which later, after
the declaration
of independence [inaudible]
was called independence hall.
The structure started in 1732
and was finished in 1741,
so very close to the publication
of the first front cover.
Even though the famous bell was
not added before the 1750's.
The staple on the right side
is most likely the first
Presbyterian Church
in Philadelphia.
We don't have any other
map of the 1740's,
which can prove my
hypothesis, but in comparison
to the front cover as it
appears in the 1760's,
the towers are still displayed.
So they are taken with
into the new design.
This offers us the opportunity
to compare the front cover
with this map, which
was drawn 10 years
after the first almanac was
published in the 1750's.
We can assume that Saur stayed
with the two buildings
he included
in the issue before the
1760's, and when we look
on the map produced by
George Heeb [phonetic]
and Nicholas Scull, here in a
reproduction from the 1900's,
which shows not just the
skyline of Philadelphia
but also explains what churches
and important buildings
we can see.
We are able to determine which
steeples are shown to us by Saur
in both almanacs,
and considering the time the
buildings were constructed
and their appearance
in the city,
we can identify the State House
and the First Presbyterian
Church
as the two prominent buildings
on the front cover up to 1759.
One of the other
steeples appearing
after 1760 can easily be
recognized as Christ Church,
since we know that this was the
tallest building in Philadelphia
and in fact in North
America at the time.
That leaves one tower
or steeple unidentified.
Though we can be quite confident
about the ones we have
identified so far,
the fourth one is much more
difficult, and we are not able
to state whether it
is the court house
or the Quaker meeting house.
But we have to admit that Saur's
front cover lacks the accuracy
for us to be sure which steeple
belonged to which church.
We can narrow it down and
build a coherent argument,
but as Saur never stated himself
what he intended to show us,
we have to be very careful
regarding appearances
of the city.
If we now look at the front
cover as it appears after 1770,
we can see that the number
of towers is still the same,
but the design has changed,
and there is no path leading
any longer to the two people,
which we can spot in the front.
But we see that the harbor has
grown, and we have more docks
between the meeting
point and the city.
The last front cover was
probably not produced any longer
by Saur Jr. himself but by
Justice Fox, who was apprentice
and worker in the Saur
Press and besides his skill
in producing woodcuts, he was
also the one producing the ink
for the Saur Press, ink
which was still famous
at the beginning of
the 19th Century.
Now we take a look on the
top of the front cover.
As pointed out before, it
changes over the time slightly,
and the banner, 1760,
and the night sky, 1770,
were included up to 1770.
But most importantly we have
Hermes, and not an angle
as Everan H. Castle [phonetic]
has described it in one
of the first analyzers
of this almanac in 1882.
Hermes as a symbol can be
found quite often in almanacs
in British North America.
Safe travels through the
countryside and most importantly
over the ocean were crucial
to the life of the people
and the Hermes is the symbol
for traveling and for trade,
so it was an important
reference.
We have to be aware
that although one hand
reached the colony safely,
it didn't necessarily mean
that one would never
cross the Atlantic again
or that one wouldn't need people
to cross it [inaudible]
directly or indirectly.
For printers and for any other
settlers, trades were crucial
because almost everyone
in the colonies relied
on goods coming across
the Atlantic.
Saur himself relied on
special paper from Europe
because he tried to
establish a colored almanac,
which required different
kind of paper
that was not produced
in the colonies.
Also, regarding news,
all the settlers,
not only in Pennsylvania,
relied on the ocean.
Almost all the information
coming
into the colonies was
brought in by ship,
even to some extent
news from Boston
or New York were
shipped to Philadelphia.
News often travelled
faster via ship.
And as well, these ships coming
from the West Indies brought
news and goods, which were sold
in British North America.
In Henry Miller's
newspaper, the [inaudible],
approximately 40 percent of
the newspaper was reserved
for advertisements of all
kinds, and many of the goods,
like sugar or rum
that were imported
from the Caribbean Isles.
Safe travels were a thing
everyone should wish for,
and settlers in the British
colonies were particularly
relying on that.
What is missing from the
cover at least with respect
to other almanacs is a zodiac.
The zodiac can be found
on many other almanacs,
and we cannot determine
why Saur excluded it.
One explanation could
be his religious belief,
but we lack any information
in this regard.
But as we missed the
zodiac, we have a rainbow
that the Hermes seems
to walk on.
The banner we can find since
1760 do not change from issue
to issue but were
changed according
to events happening
in that time.
It starts with [foreign
language],
wars and rumors of wars.
In 1765, it reads [foreign
language] and in 1767
with the end of the
struggles after the French
and the Indian War, the motto
said [foreign language] hopes
and better times.
As already pointed out,
afterward Saur changed motto
back and forth in accordance
with the political situation.
Now that we have talked about
the [foreign language] almanac,
we will take a look on
the [foreign language]
from Enrique Miller
or Henry Miller.
A printer originally
from Switzerland
who crossed the Atlantic
several times and lived as well
in London for a couple of years.
The first example was
published in the year 1763
in Philadelphia, then still
under the name [foreign
language].
The front cover appears for the
first time in 1767 at least here
in the Rare Books
Division of the Library
of Congress and is on display.
Miller was one of the
first important printers
in Philadelphia.
He published in both
English and in German
and offered translation
into French and Dutch.
The front cover from this
almanac reminds us partly
of the front cover of
the [foreign language]
but from a different
perspective.
While Saur with whom Miller
was not particular friends
and in fact Miller brought
forward public accusation
against Saur, calling him
pedantic and boastful,
while Saur shows a view
from north of Philadelphia,
Miller shows us the
one from the other side
of the Delaware River.
Although the view seems not
to be 100 percent accurate,
on the front part of
the cover, we can see,
we look very closely,
a pier of a ferry.
It's hard to see, which appears
to be one of the two ferries,
I have a closeup here, still
then it's very difficult
to realize, which
appears to be one
of the two ferries
crossing the Delaware River
from New Jersey to Philadelphia.
We can see both of those fairies
in this map from Nicholas Scull,
one of the most cartographers
for Philadelphia
and the entire region
up to the 1760's.
Though the map was published
in 1762, the very year
when the almanac was
produced for the first time,
Scull died in 1761, one year
before the map was published.
It is probably Daniel Cooper's
ferry, which you can see here.
When we compare the
perspective from the map
and the front cover, it
seems to be about right,
but the really important
reference
for this front cover image
is another map by George Heeb
and Nicholas Scull
from the 1750's,
which we have seen
before, an eastern prospect
of the city of Philadelphia.
If we compare the front cover,
we realize that Miller took
almanac everything from the map
of Heeb and Scull,
and since we know
that Miller advertised the
shop of the editor of this map,
Matthew Clarkson, we can
conclude that Miller was aware
of this map and for that
he used it as inspiration
or maybe even [inaudible]
produced by Clarkson.
Although we have to remember
that the map with the skyline
of Philadelphia was drawn in
Philadelphia but sent to English
and printed there,
the front cover
of the almanac was
produced in Philadelphia.
So what is then comparable?
As we can see, the ferry
[inaudible] can be spotted
in both images.
Here we have it.
Also, the river, here again.
Also, the river with it's
ships looks familiar, and then,
of course, there is the
skyline of Philadelphia.
Even though the front cover of
the almanac is not an exact copy
of the map, we can
compare the elements
of the scenes one on one.
What we see is from
left to right.
The State House Quaker
Meeting House, courthouse,
the Christ Church, again
as the largest building
it's quite recognizable,
then followed by the Academy,
the Presbyterian Church,
and the Dutch and
Calvinist Church.
Also, we can spot the High
Street or Market Street,
which gives us the
opportunity to identify the rest
of the city bridge, and
while we do that, about here,
where the yellow or orange
arrow is, is the printing shop
of Henry Miller, so the
printer of this front cover.
At the top of the almanac, we
can see, as we have seen it
at the [foreign language]
day and night.
On the left side,
the sun is shining,
and at the top right corner,
we have the moon and the stars.
Between those, we
can see the sky
and the zodiac showing us
the ram, the bull, the twins,
the crab, and the
lion, so he lists them
in the chronological order.
Unlike the Saurs, Miller
stayed with the arrangement
of the front cover for the whole
time he published his almanac.
This one probably
looks familiar.
The next almanac was
produced in Philadelphia
by Anthony Armbruster in
the 1750's and 1760's,
and it's called [foreign
language].
It first was produced by
Armbruster in Philadelphia
and after his death by
Francis Bailey in Lancaster.
Armbruster was supported
by Benjamin Franklin.
Not only with advice but
in particular with money,
as we can see on the contract
between the two concerning
a loan Franklin gave
to Armbruster.
The example we see here
is from the year 1753,
and as we can observe,
it defers in many ways
from the almanac we
have seen so far.
At the first sight, this
almanac has little in common
with the ones we saw before.
A lot of different
scenes are taking place,
and as we have done
before, I want to start
with what is happening
at the front.
We have two people who look like
they are arriving in a country.
The one in front looks like a
typical gentleman of that time,
and we have seen something
comparable before when we look
at the almanac of Saur.
It appears to be a European, and
it's looking in the direction
of the countryside
in front of him,
which lies on the
right-hand side.
He seems to cover his eyes,
and in his left hand he
holds a book, which is open.
Behind him, we spot what appears
to be a woman depicted like,
and I have to put as
many hyphens up as I can,
Indians are from
time to time depicted
in European images of that time.
She is barefoot and wears
no shirt, and she appears
to have [inaudible]
around her body and ankles.
A rider seems to approach
both, offering them a paper
on which is written
calendar in German.
In contrast to the content
of the [foreign language],
the rider indicates that the
almanac contains information
which are far more topical
than the news delivered
from [foreign language].
Another hint given by
the rider could indicate
that the intended audience
of the almanac in contrast
to the [foreign language],
which was considered an almanac
for common people or peasants,
the rider could be seen
as an indicator that
the almanac was designed
for a more sophisticated
readership,
the horse contradicts
the snail we have seen
on the [foreign language]
as a symbol for slowness
and also steadiness,
and as we have seen it
at the cover of Barctus.
Behind the rider, we see a
few ships along the coast,
and on the left side
is a ruin and a statue.
The ruins though do not
strike us like lost cites
from precolonial times
but rather remind us
from idolized ruins we can find
in central Europe in the middle
of the 18th Century, trying
to imitate and idolize
to those in Italy and Greece.
There are several possible
explanations of these ruins,
but as they remind us of
imagined ruins built south
of the alps, it could also be a
reference to cultures in Central
and South America, again
in an idolized way.
What makes this slightly
more plausible is the village
of natives in the background,
which is presented to us
with a wooden house
and an Indian in front
of the village only wearing
what appears to be a grass skirt
and having a bow in his hand.
The Indian seems to point in
the direction of the city,
which can be described as
a Christian city in light
of the crucifixes on top
of some towers or steeples.
In the front of the city,
we see a fortification.
As we know that Armbruster
printed in Philadelphia,
we now could assume that this
is an image of that city,
but it does not seem possible
to prove this hypothesis.
We know that there was a
battery in front of Philadelphia
down the Delaware River,
and Indians were also living
west from Philadelphia.
We could reach though,
the conclusion
that we are again
seeing Philadelphia
on this front cover.
But we don't have the same
reliable source to prove it
as we have with the
almanacs from Saur and Miller
and the map of Heeb and Scull.
Looking into the sky, we
have an angle, and not Hermes
as we've before,
blowing a trumpet
from which comes the word
[foreign language] or peace.
The words coming out of the
trumpets were changed from time
to time as we have see it
in the [foreign language]
with the banner over
Hermes, but I will come back
to this in a few seconds.
On the left side, we see the
moon, representing the night,
and on the right side the
sun, representing the day.
We also have a zodiac showing us
again the beginning of the cycle
as we have seen it before.
But I want to concentrate on the
[foreign language] for a moment.
The [foreign language]
shows us a man in profile.
He is crowned with something
looking like a [inaudible]
and around him we can
read [foreign language],
so George II, king of Britain.
But let us compare this
one from the 1750's
with a later version from 1779.
What we have here is the
same front cover used
as Armbruster's death by Francis
Bailey, who was printing it
in Lancaster and not longer in
Philadelphia, and we realized
that this is exactly
the same image
as we have seen before
except that the writing
around the hatch of George
isn't there any longer.
And we see beside him
the word Washington.
[laughter] And the angel
proclaims [foreign language],
the father of this country.
In 1783, though the
writing is completely gone
and the angel states
[foreign language]
as Saur's Hermes has
shown us on his banner
in the 1760's during the
French and Indian war,
now of course referring
to the Revolutionary War.
In conclusion, we can
see that the front covers
of German language almanacs
in the British colonies
in North America
address the wide variety
of images, themes and topics.
That Philadelphia has such
a huge impact on several
of these almanacs is
understandable considering the
important role the city and
it's harbor have for immigrants,
particularly for
immigrants from Germany.
Almanacs were widely distributed
among German settler, and many,
although they were living
and working on new land,
remembered their
homeland and wanted
to have something
familiar to read.
It is not a coincidence that
all the almanacs presented today
defer in their appearance from
the ones printed in English,
as we have seen for
instance looking
on Franklin's Poor Richard.
The collection to the origins
of German American settlers
can be grasped in many
of those pictures, referring
to German heritage not only
with the use of German
language but also quoting images
from almanacs printed
in German territories.
But interestingly enough,
the images offered to us
by those almanacs, whether
in fact it's Philadelphia
or the coast with Indians
and ruins are all
leading the settlers
in one direction, into America.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
>> We have time for a
couple of questions,
and then people are invited
to come and take a look
at the various scenes in
Philadelphia in manuscript.
You can understand why
it is such a joy to them
in our reading room because
you could remained occupied
with one almanac for hours.
>> Alexander Knirim: Is
this an invitation or?
>> Absolutely.
>> Alexander Knirim: Oh, okay.
>> So if you have questions,
please raise your hand.
>> I was struck by the amount
of British imagery that appeared
in the ship, where the
[inaudible] coming off the ship,
there's a [inaudible]
in the background,
and then of course later
as he's coming out,
George II is given
a prominent place.
What can we learn from that
about the sense of identity
in these communities, and
these were obviously people
who were still very connected
to their German heritage,
and yet they [inaudible] symbols
of the Britishness
in their depicture.
>> Alexander Knirim:
They most certainly do.
So what happens is, that
is the main question
of the whole project I'm
working on is the question,
what are those settlers
feeling like.
So they obviously are
not any longer German,
but they are mostly
referred to as citizens
of the British crown, and
they saw themselves as well
as such citizens,
but the reference
of the Germaness is mostly
an outside perspective
so many people refer to them,
many British people refer
to them as the Germans,
on the other hand among
themselves they were far more
discussing what really they are,
but it's true, they are often,
when they speak to a
[inaudible] and also
to other people referring
to themselves
as people of the British crown.
And Saur, for instance, was
very supportive at the beginning
of the Revolutionary War
of the British side and not
from the ones of the
revolution years.
So that is, that is why that
is so common [inaudible]
as well a lot of British
ships which were used
to bring over German settlers.
>> Alexander Knirim:
But the German crown,
[inaudible] British
crown is German.
Everyone from Wartenberg
would contradict
that pretty much, yeah.
So that is the whole problem
we have to address when we talk
about that time, we
have no Germaness.
So and then people from Anova,
it's not the same as someone
from Prussia, and from
Wartenberg, or from Bavaria,
so there were various lines,
and language is one binding part
of it but not the only one.
>> But the [inaudible] of the
German states was according
to the religion of the ruler,
and the Germans are much more,
you know, akin to the rule,
and if the ruler is the crown,
there is risk to the
ruler who is the crown.
I mean the Germans
are, you know, very,
very much into who is in charge.
>> Alexander Knirim: Yes, they
are, and the [foreign language]
from 1555, which you're
referring to, is an act of law,
which actually made
some people move
because the religion
changed sometimes.
>> Exactly.
>> Alexander Knirim: But I
would contradict that as someone
from Wartenberg or from
Bavaria would see a king
from Anova sitting on the
British throne as his ruler,
I would contradict that.
>> Because they were able
to get out of Wartenberg
because of the [inaudible].
>> Alexander Knirim: Saur did.
>> Yes, they were able to get
out because of the machinations
within the crown and the fact
that they were getting them,
the Protestants,
to Pennsylvania.
>> Alexander Knirim: Yes.
That is another part of the
story of why William Penn is
so important and the Dutch
people are so important as well,
but as said before, someone
who lives in Wartenberg,
he probably could be aware
of the ruler of Britain,
but that is not for him a way
of being attached
to him in any way.
>> May I [inaudible].
>> Alexander Knirim: Yeah?
>> Just say I'm [inaudible]
and very curious about the idea
of the lame messenger.
>> Alexander Knirim: Yeah.
>> Could you tell us a little
bit more about this idea
of a snail in the messaging.
>> Alexander Knirim: So as I
said, when a messenger comes
up after the 30's Years War
when part of Central Europe are,
yeah, destroyed, and wounded
and maimed soldiers are use,
the snail is also as the hare
is a reference for fast news,
the snail is a reference
for steadiness, you can rely
on those informations because
they travelled so slowly
that when they would be wrong,
the information would have got
to you probably before the
actual information had reached
you, so that is why it was so
important and what we can see
at least when we look at
those in German and France,
that those were then created
also for not so wealthy people,
we can see that from
the information given
within the almanac.
So it was more information
of how to harvest corn,
for instance, and not so much
on [inaudible] questions
and anything else.
>> I'm going to ask
the last question,
and then we'll make
time for people
to have a chance to
see the material.
This is more about the
production of the pieces.
From what they look like,
they look like woodcuts, yes.
Have you ever seen, are the
dates and the lettering done
with [inaudible] are
they dropping the dates
of the almanac in type for one
year and then, so that balloon
that says 1779 or
whatever [inaudible].
>> Alexander Knirim:
It's mostly spared
and then put there
afterwards, yeah,
so they can use the
same font cover over
and over again without--
>> Making it a double
impression--
>> Alexander Knirim:
Yes, exactly.
>> I think [inaudible].
>> Alexander Knirim:
So the space is there,
and then they can print it in.
>> Uh-huh.
So I think, let's first
thank our speaker and then--
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.